all right
[Music]
where are you
I am Gathering the greatest from every
world
in the heavens above
the real war is coming
and I would risk everything
to ensure victory
what are you willing to risk
other president the time has come the
child is with her mother bring them to
me dead or alive
it would be an honor
the last thing my dad asked me to do was
take the knife to Adam's room first we
need to go to the Land of the Dead
don't bring people back from the dead
you have to try
what if we don't come back and we want
to die doing something important
our daughter is in danger a magisterium
won her dead
you know who they say she is
if the prophecy is true she will achieve
something far beyond your Rebellion
something changed everything was in
Balance but now the world is dying I
it hurts when we're apart
the greatest love
[Music]
is the one that you can't live without
the one that you're prepared to die for
this together
by turning back
the authority
one should be afraid of what the
authority has no power over us just
hurry worry
oh free
[Applause]
[Music]
hope
will spark
in darkness